I am an ideas activist that means I
fight for ideas I believe in to have
their place in the Sun regardless of
which side of the Equator they were born
as well I shoot I myself am from that
part of the world often euphemistically
referred to as either the global south
or the developing world but let's be
blunt about it and when we see those
ways what we really mean is the poor
world those corners of the world with
ready-made containers for the
hand-me-down ideas of other places and
other people but I'm here to depart a
little bit from the scripts and to try
and convince you that these places are
actually alive and bubbling with ideas
my real issue is where driving starts so
maybe Egypt Alexandre well we meet
Rizwan when it works outside the souk
walks into a pharmacy for hot medicine
that can prevent the blood in his
arteries from clotting he confront the
fact that despite a growing epidemic
that currently accounts for 82 percent
of all deaths in Egypt it is the
medicines that can address these
conditions that counterfeiters however
the evil geniuses they are have decided
to target can if it is making knockoff
medicines likely for Islam my team and I
working in partnership with a largest
pharmaceutical company in Africa have
placed unique codes think of them like
one-time passwords on each pack of the
best-selling hot medicine in Egypt
so when Rizwan buys cough medicine you
can key in
these one-time passwords to a toll-free
shortcode that we've set up on all the
telecom companies in Egypt for free he
gets a message call it a message of life
which reassures him that this medicine
is not one of the twelve percent of all
medicines in Egypt there are
counterfeits from the gorgeous banks of
the Nile we glide into the beautiful
Rift Valley of King uh in Arak town we
meet a link salt-of-the-earth fellow
when he walks into an agro dealer's shop
all he wants is certified and proper
cabbage feats but if you were to plant
them we'll use the harvest rich enough
they can pay for the school fees of his
children that's what he wants
unfortunately by the reckoning of most
international organizations twenty
percent of all the seeds so the easting
and southern Africa of questionable
quality sometimes outrightly fake
lightly fully once again our team has
been at work and working with a lead in
agricultural regulator in Kenya we've
digitized the entire certification
process for seeds in that country every
seed millet sorghum maize such that when
only in cou kissing a code on a pocket
of mallets it is able to retrieve a
digital certificate that are shows him
that the seed is properly certified from
Kenya we had to NIDA in India where the
irrepressible Ambika is holding on very
fast to her dream or becoming an elite
athlete safe in the knowledge that
because of our ingredients rating
technology she's not gonna mean just
something acidentally which will mess up
hadoop in tests and kick her out of the
sports she laughs
finally we are lights in Ghana my own
home country for another problem this
address
the problem of under vicinity nor poor
palliative vaccinations you see when you
put some vaccines into the bloodstream
of an infant you are giving them a
lifetime insurance against dangerous
diseases that can them or kill
them sometimes it's for a lifetime the
problem is that vaccines are delicate
organisms really and they need to be
stored between 2 degrees and 8 degrees
and if you don't do that they lose their
potency and they no longer confer the
immunity the child deserves working with
computer vision scientists we've
conveyed as simple markers on the valves
of vaccines in 20 my regard has crude
thermometers so these patterns change
slowly over time in response to
temperature on to they leave a distinct
pattern on the surface of the vaccine
said that a nurse with the scan of the
phone can detect if the vaccine was
stored properly in the right temperature
and therefore is still good for use
before administering this to the child
literally securing the next generation
these are some of the solutions at work
saving lives
redeeming societies in this part of the
world but I would remind you that there
are powerful ideas behind them and I
recover few one the social trust is not
the same as interpersonal trust to that
the division between consumption and
regulation not increasingly
interdependent world is no longer viable
and 3 that decentralized autonomy
regardless of what our block children to
the US and the West whom I respect a lot
see and are as important as reinforcing
social accountability feedback loops
just want ideas now every time I go
somewhere and I did this speech and I
make you know these comments and I
provide these examples people say well
if these ideas are so damn brilliant why
did not everywhere I've never heard of
it I want to show you the reason why
you've not heard of these ideas it's
exactly the point I made in the
beginning and that is
there are parts of the world whose good
ideas simply don't scale because of the
latitude on which they were born I call
that mental latitude imperialism that
really the reason now you make counter
and say well maybe it's an important
problem use of an obscure problem the
path of the world why do you want to
globalize that problem I mean they are
better look out what if in response I
told you that actually and the line each
of these problems are described it's a
fundamental issue of the breakdown of
trust in markets and institutions and
there's nothing more global more
Universal closer to you and I done the
problem of trusts for example a quarter
of all the seafood market in the u.s. is
falsely labeled so that when you buy a
tuna or salmon sandwich in Manhattan
you're eating something that could be
banned for being toxic in Japan
literally most of you have heard of a
time when horse meat was masquerading as
beef in burger patties in Europe you
have what you don't know is that a good
chunk of these fake meat patties were
also contaminated cadmium which can
damage your kidneys this was Europe many
of you are aware of plane crashes and
you worry about plane crash because
every now and then one of them intrude
into your consciousness but I bet you
don't know that a single investigation
uncovered 1 million counterfeit
incidents in their own article supply
chain in the US so this is a global
problem first off it's a group a problem
the only reason we are not addressing
with the agency deserves is that the
best solutions the most advanced
solutions the most progressive solutions
and unfortunate in parts of the world
where solutions don't scale and that is
why it's not surprising that attempts to
create the same verification models for
pharmaceuticals are now a decade behind
in the USA in Europe what is already
available in Nigeria a decade and
costing a hundred times more and that is
why when you walk into a Walgreens in
New York you cannot check the source of
your medicine but you can do that in
Maiduguri in northern Nigeria that is
the relative
derivative so we go back to the issue of
ideas
remember solutions are merely packaged
ideas so it ideas that are most
important in the world where we
modernize the ideas of the global south
we cannot create globally inclusive
problem-solving models now you might say
well that's bad but in such a world
where we have so many other problems do
we need another course I say yes we need
another cause and actually that course
will surprise you the cause of
intellectual justice is that what's
intellectual justice in a world of human
rights abuses and I explained this way
all the solutions to the other problems
that affect us and confront us need
solutions so you need the best ideas to
address them and that is why today I ask
you can we all give it one time for
intellectual justice
[Applause]